- Here's how I made $1 million this year
as a solo serial entrepreneur
I wake up at 5:00 a.m. every day.
I meditate for 30 minutes.
I journal for 10 minutes.
I practice gratitude for five minutes.
I love you!
I do my daily jog while
listening to Naval's podcast
on how to get rich.
I sign up for a drop
shipping VIP masterclass.
I get on a call with my mentor.
- Like, I got my entire fist in there.
It was crazy.
Sorry, what was your question?
- I work 60 hours a week
in social media marketing.
I invest that money into crypto.
I run a dropshipping
business selling socks.
I write a personal finance newsletter
with affiliate marketing.
I sell a course called how
I make 1 million a year
in your 20s.
I do consulting calls for $500 an hour.
I bought three properties
and I flipped them
and my dad gifted me $1
million for my birthday.
And that's how you make 1
million a year in your 20s.
(microphone clattering)